ON THE GROUND THERE, PAMELA?
>> BRUTAL INDEED.
ARLETTE SAENZ, THANK YOU.
>>> WELL, RUSSIA INVADED UKRAINE
WITH OVERWHELMING MILITARY MIGHT
AND A CATASTROPHIC UNDER
ESTIMATION OF THE UKRAINIAN WILL
TO FIGHT FOR THE HOMELAND.
I WANT TO BRING BACK A COUPLE
WHO EMBODY THE FIGHT.
BOTH POPULAR SINGERS AND A
COUPLE.
HIS WIFE IS SAFE IN NEW YORK AND
HE'S FIGHTING.
THANK YOU BOTH FOR COMING ON.
REALLY APPRECIATE IT.
I THOUGHT IT WOULD BE
INTERESTING TO HEAR YOUR
PERSPECTIVE AS A MARRIED COUPLE
GOING THROUGH THIS.
SINCE WE TALKED TWO WEEKS AGO,
THE RUSSIANS HAVE PULLED BACK
FROM THE CAPITAL.
WONDERING WHAT YOUR EXPERIENCE
IS THERE.
WHAT ARE YOU SEEING?
>> HELLO, EVERYBODY.
SO I WAS COUPLE OF DAYS HEEF
HORRIBLE PICTURES.
ALL THAT WAS SAID TO ME, ALL
THIS IS TRUE SO A LOT OF KILLED
BY RUSSIAN PEOPLE AND THIS IS
EXACTLY LIKE IT.
BUT THE MAIN IS THAT NOW REALLY
UNDERSTAND THAT RUSSIANS ARE
EVIL.
IT'S EXACTLY EVIL WHAT THEY ARE
DOING AND AS A RESULT, WHAT WE
SEE SO BUT, BUT, UKRAINIAN ARMY
CONTINUES TO COUNTER ATTACK.
AND LIBERATING OUR CITIES AND WE
KEEP MOVING TO OUR VICTORY AND
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT TO SAY WE
NEED MORE POWER, MORE GUNS AND
MORE MILITARY HELP FOR DOING
THIS MUCH FASTER BECAUSE SUC,
EVERY NEXT DAY IT IS MORE
KILLED, CIVILIAN, PEACEFUL
PEOPLE.
EVERY NEXT DAY ALLOWS RUSSIANS
TO KILL OUR NATION MORE AND
MORE.
SO IT'S VERY IMPORTANT FOR US
FOR MORE SANCTIONS, FOR MORE
GUNS AND EVERYTHING THAT CAN
HELP US TO DEFIELD OUR COUNTRY
AND GET THE VICTORY AGAINST THE
RUSSIANS.
>> I WANT TO BRING YOU IN.
THIS MUST BE SO DIFFICULT FOR
YOU SEEING YOUR COUNTRY UNDER
SIEGE.
KNOWING YOUR HUSBAND IS PART OF
THAT LAST LINE OF DEFENSE.
HOW ARE YOU HOLDING UP?
I BELIEVE IF I'M NOT MISTAKEN,
YOU TWO HAVE A CHILD, RIGHT?
>> YES, WE HAVE THREE.
TWO BOYS AND ONE GIRL.
OF COURSE, I LEAVE KYIV WITH
CHILD AND 24 FEBRUARY BUT MY
HEART AND, YOU KNOW, HEART OF
ALL UKRAIIANS NOT IN UKRAINE
BUT OVER THE WORLD AND TODAY AND
YESTERDAY, WE HAVE A CONCERT
ABOUT THIS IN CHICAGO AND NEW
YORK TODAY AND IT'S THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE WHO CAME TODAY TO TAKE
THE TICKETS AND THIS MORNING GO
TO UKRAINE AND WE ARE PRAYING
FOR UKRAINE AND, YOU KNOW, TODAY
WHAT HAPPENED TODAY, YESTERDAY
IN BUCHA IS TOO MUCH EVIL
PICTURES, WHAT IS EVIL, WHO IS
EVIL ON THE PLANET.
ON THE PLANET.
AND THIS WORLD.
ALL HUMANITY CAN STOP THIS.
JUST STOP THIS.
CLOSE, CLOSE GOOGLE.
CLOSE MICROSOFT.
EMBARGO AND ANOTHER, WHAT WE CAN
DO WE MUST DO.
BECAUSE IT'S NOT NORMAL.
IT'S NOT -- YOU KNOW, I CAN'T
BELIEVE, I CAN'T BELIEVE THAT
I'M NOT IN -- I'M NOT SLEEPING
ONE MONTH AND HAVE -- I CAN'T
BELIEVE I'M NOT SLEEPING.
I WOULD GO HOME WHAT CAN I SAY?
PLEASE, WORLD, WAKE UP.
>> YEAH.
YOU KNOW, YOU BROUGHT UP BUCHA
AND THE HORRIFIC IMAGES OUT OF
THERE.
BUCHA IS NOT FAR FROM WHERE YOU
ARE.
>> YEAH.
>> WHAT IS YOUR REACTION TO WHAT
WE ARE SEEING COMING OUT OF
THERE?
>> YOU KNOW, WHAT WE SEE NOW IS
TOTALLY HATE.
AND WE ARE ASKING WHY.
WHY?
ALL THAT HAPPENS, IT CAN BE
PREVENTED.
IT COULD BE PREVENTED.
BUT, YOU KNOW, THIS HATE AND THE
HELP, THE HELP OF THE UNITED
STATES AND PRAYERS ALL OVER THE
WORLD GIVE US POWER TO FIGHT AND
TO PROTECT THE FUTURE, NOT ONLY
UKRAINIAN PEOPLE BUT THE FUTURE
WORLD FIGHTING DEMOCRACY AGAINST
TOTAL REGIME.
>> YEAH, GO AHEAD -- SORRY.
>> THANK YOU FOR SHOWING THIS.
THANK YOU FOR HELPING US SPREAD
THIS INFORMATION BECAUSE IT'S
VERY IMPORTANT TO GIVE PEOPLE
TRUTH WHAT IS HAPPENING MOW AND
YOU KNOW THIS IS A SMALL CITY
BUCHA BUT THE ARMY WILL BE
CAPTURED AND OTHER BIG CITIES.
UNFORTUNATELY, WE WILL SEE THE
SAME BECAUSE EVERYWHERE WHERE
THERE IS A RUSSIAN ARMY,
EVERYWHERE WILL BE THE SAME.
>> YEAH.
>> UNDERSTAND IT AND PLEASE
BELIEVE IN IT THAT IT'S
HAPPENING NOW.
IT'S NOT A PROVOCATION, IT'S
TRUTH.
THOSE DIED PEOPLE, THOSE KILLED
PEOPLE WITH TIED HANDS BY THE
SHOOTING IN THEIR HEADS,
PEACEFUL PEOPLE.
YOU KNOW, I'M A SOLDIER AND IF I
EVEN WILL DIE IN THE BATTLE,
IT'S NORMAL BECAUSE SOLDIERS
FIGHTING WITH SOLDIERS CIVILIAN
PEACEFUL PEOPLE, IT'S NOT NORMAL
WHEN THEY DO THIS TOTALLY IT NOT
NORMAL.
>> NONE OF THIS IS NORMAL.
NONE OF THIS IS NORMAL AND IT IS
JUST SO IMPORTANT TO HEAR FROM
YOU BOTH AND YOUR PERSPECTIVES.
YOU HAVE BEEN IN THE MILITARY
NOW FIGHTING, PROTECTING YOUR
HOMELAND SEEING ALL OF THIS
FIRST HAND AND TO YOU, ALIOS,
BEING SO FAR AWAY FROM YOUR
HOMELAND AND YOUR HUSBAND
WORRIED PROBABLY AROUND THE
CLOCK ABOUT HIS SAFETY AND HOW
HE IS DOING AND I WONDER HOW
YOU'VE BEEN ABLE TO KIND OF
BASICALLY BECOME A SINGLE MOM
WITH THREE KIDS AND KEEP IN
TOUCH WITH YOUR HUSBAND AND WORK
THROUGH THIS BECAUSE I IMAGINE
IT INCREDIBLY DIFFICULT FOR YOU.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH.
YOU KNOW, IT'S NOT POLITICAL
HISTORY.
WE UNDERSTAND IT'S UKRAINE THIS
STORY ABOUT HUMAN DAY, ABOUT OUR
KIND HEARTS.
THIS IS MORE IMPORTANT IN THE
WORLD AND THIS SITUATION IN
UKRAINE SHOWING, SHOWING THAT
HUMANITY, HUMANITY AND WE MUST
STOP THIS.
I HOPE I PRAY AND I KNOW WE ARE
HAVING POWERFUL ENERGY FROM HERE
FROM THIS PLACE AND I HOPE OUR
ENERGY AND YOUR HELP AND HELP
FROM OTHER COUNTRIES WHO PRAY
FOR US WE WILL WIN.
HUMANITY WILL WIN.
HEARTS AND SOULS.
>> SWEETIE, LET THEY SPEAK IF
POSSIBLE.
SO IT IS VERY BIG ASSISTANCE TO
UKRAINIAN SOLDIERS THAT THEIR
WIVES TOOK THE RESPONSIBILITY
FOR THEY CHILDRENS AND WHEN OUR
WIVES FIND SAFETY PLACE WITH OUR
CHILDRENS, WE CAN FIGHT BRAVELY.
SO THANK YOU, SWEETIE, FOR DOING
THIS AND I WANT TO SAY THANK YOU
FOR A LOT OF UKRAINIAN WIVES
WHICH NOW ARE TAKING RESPONSE
AND TRIES TO DO ALL THE BEST FOR
THE KIDS WHILE UKRAINIAN
SOLDIERS ARE FIGHTING.
IT'S ALSO VERY GOOD -- IT'S ALSO
VERY IMPORTANT SUPPORT FOR US.
>> AWE.
MY HEART IS MELTING HEARING
THAT.
I KNOW -- GO AHEAD.
I WANT YOU TO